just saw the players there  playing instantly  yeah and I'm just trying to count  because the last Pawn push was quite a  long time ago and uh yeah I mean here  dude I need to push a pawn at some point  he's got to make sure he pushes White's  g-pawn perhaps for example before the 50  move rule because otherwise the game's  declared to draw it look at this they're  just going back and forth no progress to  be made  and and there's drama Liam Lee has  suddenly won the second Blitz game  against America's class to take that one  to Armageddon wow we will show the end  of that game a bit later but look at  this time to scramble now yeah Magnus it  looks like he blew it he got over  excited and do the smiling now and oh he  blunt he blunders into a repetition of  the position  it's a draw  it's automatically a draw he blunders  into repetition that is crazy  Prague wins the match in Armageddon with  a draw in that final game